preparing for monday it's been a long
hard winter in the uk's education system
but the banners are going up and the
students are going back
at horsehall cme junior school friends
and classmates who've been separated
since the start of january
are ready to be reunited again it might
be a little bit strange seeing all my
school friends again because i mean i
haven't seen them in like six
weeks and i'm also feeling pretty
excited seeing them again
and i'm looking forward to going back to
for a normal routine
it's gonna be
more fun because we have we'll have more
than seven
people in the classroom and it's gonna
be
um it's gonna be more exciting many
parents
are just as excited this is what we're
waiting for honestly
i'm with kids all the time my husband is
working all day so
everything is on my shoulder so i'm
really glad they coming back to school
is a good for their future because it's
not better place than school you know
and for education
so it's amazing yeah i think we're all
just tired we're emotionally exhausted
and we're on our
last little um nice little battery of
kind of of energy so looking forward to
getting back to normal
so we've had to make a lot of changes to
the school
mrs wand the head teacher here has been
finalizing her reopening plan
so every classroom has new equipment in
it to make sure the children are
safe and covered secure there have been
classes run throughout lockdown for the
children of key workers
such as healthcare staff but more than
eighty percent of this school's pupils
have been absent since january the fifth
these empty classrooms are going to
suddenly fill again
for what promises to be an overwhelming
return children need to be happy and
settled
and for some children especially this
last period of lockdown
it's been really tough they've been
stuck inside they haven't had the normal
contact with
wider friends and family so i think it's
going to be quite difficult for those
children to
come back and reintegrate into school
but we've got lots of things in place
for them
in scotland and wales children won't all
return to full-time schooling
until after easter another month from
now
but in england nearly seven million
pupils are returning on mass
the uk government has opted for a big
bang return to school
bringing all the children back on the
same date
subject to the school's ability to
conduct tests
but teaching unions have expressed
concerns
the prime minister resisted calls for
children to go back after the february
half term
and the extra two weeks of closure has
allowed the uk's seven day average
to drop from twelve thousand new cases a
day to just six and a half thousand a
day but amid all the excitement of
friends reunited at the school gates
the government's scientific advisors
face a nervous wait
to see what impact the school's
reopening will have
on that crucial infection data paul
brennan
al-jazeera woke